follow Lange focus on Facebook Twitter
and Instagram hello everyone welcome to
the Lange focus channel and my name is
Paul today's topic is the Celtic
languages Celtic languages are today
spoken mainly in the British Isles where
they've existed alongside English since
the Middle Ages the numbers are not
exactly clear because the Celtic
languages have gone through declines and
revivals and people have varying degrees
of ability so take these numbers with a
grain of salt but there are around a
million speakers of Celtic languages in
total that includes Welsh with around
five hundred and eight thousand speakers
and around three hundred and ten
thousand fluent speakers mainly in Wales
then there's Irish Gaelic which has
around 80,000 proficient speakers who
use it outside of school but around two
million people have at least some
knowledge of it mainly in Ireland and to
some extent in Northern Ireland
then there's Scottish Gaelic which has
around 57,000 native speakers and around
87,000 people with some knowledge of the
language mainly in Scotland there is
also a small Scottish Gaelic community
of around 2,300 people and Cape Breton
Nova Scotia in Canada then there's the
Breton language spoken by around two
hundred and twenty six thousand people
mainly in the Brittany region of France
that figure of two hundred and twenty
six thousand includes students in
bilingual schools then there's the
Cornish language spoken in Cornwall
which came close to extinction in the
nineteenth century but has undergone a
revival and now has a few thousand
fluent speakers and then there's the
Manx language spoken on the Isle of Man
which has only around a hundred native
speakers and a couple thousand people
who can speak some Manx today they're
not spoken by a very large number of
people and they're mostly limited to the
British Isles and to Brittany in France
but historically the Celtic languages
were once spoken over a much larger area
than they are today during the first
millennium BCE they were spoken across
much of Europe from the Iberian
Peninsula all the way over to the Black
Sea
and even in part of Asia Minor one
probable proto Celtic culture was the
urn field culture of Central Europe in
the Late Bronze Age it was a flourishing
culture from around 1200 BCE its
language was at least likely an early
form of Celtic if not
proto Celtic and we think so partly
based on place-name evidence proto
Celtic developed into various Celtic
languages which were spoken over a wide
area in Europe the earliest attested
Celtic language is the LA Pontic
language the language of the goalless
Enka culture that descended from the urn
field culture there are about a hundred
and forty lip on tick inscriptions that
were discovered in northern Italy and
southern Switzerland these inscriptions
date from around 550 BCE to 100 BCE the
goalless inca culture had strong
connections with the neighbouring
hallstatt culture the major Celtic
culture at that time these languages on
the European mainland and in Asia Minor
are referred to as the continental
languages this is a geographic grouping
not a linguistic one and there are no
particular linguistic innovations that
would make them a linguistic grouping
here are some continental Celtic
languages that might ring a bell there's
the Gaulish language spoken in Gaul with
in present-day France and Galician
spoken in Asia Minor around present-day
Ankara Turkey the continental Celtic
languages are all extinct Celtic
speakers began to die out or become
assimilated into the Roman culture by
around 200 BCE before the death and
assimilation of Celtic speakers on the
mainland some Celtic speakers migrated
to the British Isles the Celtic
languages that developed in the British
Isles are known as the insular Celtic
languages the insular Celtic languages
are still alive today there are two
groups of insular Celtic languages QED
Celtic or [ __ ] Delic languages which
include Irish Scottish and Manx Gaelic
and the PIA Celtic or breath onik
languages which include Breton Cornish
and Welsh these two groups of insular
Celtic languages are not intelligible
with each other but within each group
there is some degree of intelligibility
depending on the dialects being spoken
the two groups of insular Celtic
languages evolved from a common ancestor
the oldest known insular Celtic language
is a form of archaic Irish sometimes
called primitive Irish it is found in
the Ottoman scription from the early 4th
century CE II algum is an alphabet that
was used to write Irish as it grew from
primitive Irish into old Irish and was
used until about the 9th century old
Irish eventually developed into the
modern Irish Gaelic of today speakers of
old Irish also migrated to Scotland
where it eventually
developed into Scottish Gaelic and to
the isle of man were it evolved into
Manx while primitive Irish arose in
Ireland common breath Annika rose in
Great Britain common breath onic is the
ancestor of all the P Celtic or breath o
neck languages the Pictish language
which went extinct by the 12th century
CE II may have been a breath onic
language but it's possible that Pictish
was related to birth on ik but not
descended from it over the course of a
few centuries breath on ik dialects
evolved into Welsh Cornish Breton and
kumbhak which is extinct the Celtic
languages were under great pressure
during this time Breton is in fact
spoken in continental Europe in the
Brittany region of France even though
it's an insular Celtic language it has
been spoken there since the 6th century
CE II when some Celtic speakers fled
during the anglo-saxon invasion of
Britain coexistence with English Britain
was ruled by the Romans from 43c II to
410 C II but after the departure of the
Romans the anglo-saxons began to invade
Britain in Britain the anglo-saxons
conquered the Celtic peoples and either
eliminated them or intermarried with
them depending on the source you consult
eventually replacing the Celtic
languages with Old English but not in
Wales and Cornwall which remained Celtic
in Scotland Gaelic speakers from Ireland
migrated to the west coast around the
same time that anglo-saxons migrated to
the east coast then Scottish Gaelic
began to develop in Scotland Gaelic
coexisted with the old English dialects
that would later develop into Scots and
Scots English and in the year 1707
Scotland formed a union with England and
Wales the Kingdom of Great Britain after
that Scottish Gaelic began to diminish
in use partly because English was the
language of universal education Scottish
Gaelic is today considered definitely
endangered by UNESCO as world language
project Wales came under the control of
England in the year 1280 to Welsh has
continued to be spoken until the present
day but for a long time English was
given preference as the official
language and in the 19th and 20th
centuries Welsh declined rapidly in
favour of English but efforts have been
made to conserve the Welsh language and
everybody learns at least some of it in
school and some people take their entire
public school education in Welsh and as
I mentioned before it currently has
hundreds of thousands of native speakers
Cornwall was under English control by
the mid 90s began to disappear after
England passed the act of uniformity in
1558 this was a law that made English
the sole language of church services the
Cornish language almost became extinct
and it was actually temporarily declared
extinct by UNESCO but a revival movement
in the 20th century has given new life
to the language and it is now taught in
some schools and there are now about 300
fluent Cornish speakers on the Isle of
Man the Manx language is in a similar
situation it almost became extinct but a
revival movement has resulted in a few
hundred fluent speakers of the language
there is also a Manx language primary
school they're creating a new generation
of Manx speakers Ireland became an
English colony from 1169 to 1949 Irish
remained the majority language there
until the 19th century when it was
overtaken by English despite strong
intentions to support and revive the
Irish language it continues to decline
in favour of English it is taught in
schools but not many people use the
language of their own volition outside
of schools and similar to Scottish
Gaelic it is considered definitely
endangered the Brittany region became
part of France in the 16th century in
France there is no official recognition
of any regional languages
the majority of Breton speakers today
are in their 60s or older and the number
of speakers could be dropping by 10,000
per year it is considered severely
endangered by UNESCO now let's look at
some features of Celtic languages in
general Celtic languages feature VSO
word order actually continental Celtic
languages probably had freer word order
but let's focus on the living Celtic
languages here's an example of VSO word
order in Irish Gaelic this sentence
means
I saw the man this morning Connick man
fair margin word for word it's C past
tense I the man on morning you can see
that it's vs oh another sentence this
one means the man was painting a chair
yesterday Ian farik panchal Karen a word
for word it'd be in past tense
the man progressive paint chair
yesterday you can see that it's VSO with
the auxilary
coming in first position and the main
lexical verb coming after the subject
and then there's the object next Celtic
languages feature inflected prepositions
which are basically a combination of a
preposition and a personal pronoun let's
look at an example from Welsh the
preposition meaning on is at and the
stem that comes before inflections is
adding so we have on me are now on us
are Nam on you singular and Matt on you
plural are no on him aDNA on her are
Ninh on them
Adney a similar kind of inflected
preposition exists in Semitic languages
like C Bru and Arabic next Celtic
languages feature initial consonant
mutations that is a change in the
consonant at the beginning of a word
depending on its context for example if
the word is preceded by a definite
article in the genitive case let's take
a look at this in Irish so we have the
word for man fair but if we want to say
of the man it becomes unfair and it's
similar for the dative case if we want
to say to the man it becomes tan fair
duh dun dun dun fair it may be hard to
hear a difference in that consonant but
there is a sort of softening of the F
sound in some dialects that mutated
consonant sounds something like a V
sound in other dialects it's silent
not only consonant mutations but also
vowel mutations occur in Celtic
languages as a morphological device
let's look at some examples from Welsh
vowel mutations can be used in forming
different parts of speech I becomes a so
the noun hi-oh meaning son becomes the
adjective pay log meaning sunny vowel
mutations can also be used in the
formation of a plural who becomes so the
singular noun cool
meaning boat becomes code meaning boats
Celtic languages also feature an
impersonal verb form serving as a
passive or intransitive an example from
Welsh Dutch scout means I teach the
skier means is taught or one teaches
this is an impersonal verb that is not
conjugated for person an example from
Irish Moon iam I teach moon sure is
taught one teaches in English there is
no specific verb form dedicated to the
passive you need to use an auxiliary
verb plus the past participle which has
some other functions as well differences
between the P Celtic languages and the Q
Celtic languages these two groups of
languages have had thousands of years to
diverge so there are a lot more
differences between the two branches
then there are between the languages
within them there are a lot of cognate
words shared between the two groups of
languages but you could say that they
are distant cognates because sound
changes and spelling changes have made
the words unrecognizable in many cases
the labels P Celtic and Q Celtic reflect
the way these two groups developed from
proto Celtic if we look at the cognates
that are shared between both branches in
the P Celtic branch there are words that
commonly begin with P or B while in the
Q Celtic branch they begin with C or K
or Q for example the word for what in
Irish its cane and in Welsh it's Beth
there are some other common sound
differences too for example words
beginning with s followed by E or I
which make a sure sound in the goid
ellic languages often begin with H in
the breath onic languages so the word
for old in Irish is Shan and in Welsh
it's and despite their coexistence with
English over the centuries
the Celtic languages are very distinct
from English and they're an important
part of the history and the culture and
identity of the United Kingdom and of
Ireland as well as Brittany in France
but today most of the Celtic languages
are considered to be endangered with the
English language and French dominating
whether the Celtic languages survived or
not depends on the communities to which
they are native and that brings me to
the question of the day for people from
a community where a Celtic language has
traditionally been spoken do you speak a
Celtic language do you speak that
language outside of school how valuable
do you think it is to be able to speak
that language let us know in the
comments down below be sure to follow
Leng focus on Facebook Twitter and
Instagram and once again I'd like to say
thank you to my patreon supporters
especially these ones right here for
their monthly pledges thank you for
watching and have a nice day
[Music]